die flutkatastrophe im aartal 14 wochen
ist es her dass die wassermassen alles
mit sich rissen und tod und verwüstung
zurückließen ja unser reporter peter
hell der war mehrfach im
katastrophengebiet und hat eine
beeindruckende reportage gedreht und
hier ein kurzer ausschnitt
sind sich rheinland pfalz für zehn
wochen nach der flutkatastrophe
immer noch sind die spuren der
verwüstung allgegenwärtig
seit der katastrophe ist gutachter maik
menke als sachverständiger für
gebäudeschäden unterwegs ja momentan was
man hier so vorfindet ist ein bild der
zerstörung und des geworden sieht aus
wie in einem kriegsgebiet
überall tiefe löcher einschläge spuren
an den hauswänden
krater in den
straßen
über liegt müll rum es wirklich grausam
was man hier so sieht da sieht aus wie
nach einem bombenangriff
am 15 juli hält ein anwohner mit seinem
handy fest wie die drei meter hohe
flutwelle der alles mitreißt die
wohnungen im erdgeschoss werden zerstört
die bewohner können rechtzeitig fliehen
50 denn von den behörden im stich
gelassen
[Musik]
also
heizung
ist
die jahrhundertflut hat nicht nur
tausende wohnungen und häuser zerstört
sondern auch die strom- und
versorgungsleitungen was befürchten sie
für den winter hier jetzt bei diesem
haus zum beispiel leute vergangen machen
vorher in den wohnungen die leute
frieren die leute wissen nicht wohin die
leute werden hier vermutlich andere
maßnahmen aufziehen um irgendwie wärme
in ihre wohnung zu kriegen ich will mir
gar nicht ausmalen was hier im winter
passiert ledger krasniqis wohnung wurde
durch die flut zerstört eine nachbarin
überließ ihr und den kindern dann ihre
wohnung doch die hat ebenfalls flut
schäden
ohne strom funktioniert
[Musik]
mit jacken und bei kerzenlicht peter
held der die reportage gedreht hat ist
jetzt bei uns im studio die bilder haben
wir gesehen aber was sind deine
persönlichen eindrücke naja die
eindrücke sind so das was wir gesehen
haben also man kommt wenn man ins tal
fährt in ein katastrophengebiet einigen
geht es gut den ist geholfen worden die
haben sich sehr selber helfen können es
ist eine irrsinnige solidarität unter
den anwohnern auch aber manchen geht es
immer noch sehr schlecht wir haben das
gerade gesehen es ist auch nicht nur das
physisch also dass es keinen strom gibt
dass es teilweise kein wasser gibt immer
noch nicht sondern es sind auch die
psychischen belastungen wir haben es
gesehen die die leute sind durch muss
man sagen und jetzt ist die riesige
angst vor dem winter also es gibt nach
temperaturen die gegenrichtung 0 einige
wohnungen wie wir gesehen haben haben
immer noch kein strom immer noch kein
gas keine heizung soll bis ende november
sollen 2500 wohnungen etwa mit gas
ausgestattet werden von 3500 also darf
fehlen immer noch viele sachen und wir
haben gesehen die menschen weil sie sind
verzweifelt teilweise und wenn es dann
wir waren in wohnung da ist war es jetzt
schon für 10 13 14 grad mit der jungen
mutter da haben wir 14 grad gemessen die
müssen wirklich tatsächlich mit decken
abends dasitzen und hausaufgaben machen
und da tut sich noch nichts aber peter
was ist deiner meinung schief gelaufen
also ich meine dass der winter jetzt
kommt ist klar
naja was heißt schief gelaufen ist ist
eine irrsinnige katastrophe gewesen wir
wissen in deutschland ist ein ein
blühendes bürokratie land bevor
irgendetwas passiert müssen anträge
geschrieben werden die
verantwortlichkeiten werden von a nach b
geschoben wir haben mit leuten
gesprochen die haben gesagt wir schaffen
es auch gar nicht die formulare
auszufüllen da braucht man pilotenschein
für also das ist und dann muss man auch
sagen viele menschen haben auch
sprachschwierigkeiten es sind migranten
die dort wohnen teilweise die kann das
gar nicht lesen und jetzt versucht man
so langsam purple die
verantwortlichkeiten auch zu
kanalisieren
es passiert jetzt was aber es ist
höchste zeit ist muss jetzt was gemacht
werden weil der winter steht vor der tür
und es fehlen immer noch für mehrere
hundert haushalte viel strom wasser und
wir haben auch was auch in der reportage
die leute versorgen sich teilweise
selber das heißt sie haben heizstäbe in
den wassertanks das was lebensgefährlich
ist das offene stromleitung dort in den
badezimmern sind wo eben provisorisch
versucht wird das wasser warm zu machen
und das ist natürlich lebensgefährlich
so was da jetzt gibt es ja 30 milliarden
euro die von der bundesregierung zur
verfügung gestellt werden zum teil auch
von den ländern und du hast vorhin
gesagt es gibt einige denen geht es gut
aber andere eben nicht wie wir hier
gesehen haben woran liegt das warum
kriegen die einen ein halbwegs normales
leben wieder hin und andere nicht sehr
gute zweck zu beantworten es ist immer
in der sache der verantwortlichkeiten
zum beispiel ein eigentümer der ein
wohnhaus besitzt ist dann teilweise auch
verantwortlich für die wasserversorgung
oder auch für die stromversorgung da
sagt das land du bist verantwortlich
dafür dann dauert das natürlich wir
haben ein haus
eine reportage in diesem haus gemacht wo
der eigentümer verschwunden ist er hatte
vorher erst seinen eigenen seinen
mietern gekündigt also das hängt dann
teilweise auch an den an den eigentümern
und dann hört die verantwortlichkeit von
den behörden dann teilweise auch auf und
die sagen okay dafür ist dann der
eigentümer zuständig und das ist eben
die krux an der sache also ich will
nicht ungerecht sein alle versuchen das
beste die bürokratie ist hinderlich
extrem die formulare sind teilweise
extrem hinderlich und daneben die
divergenzen zwischen eigentümer und
regierung und kommunen das müsste besser
laufen und ich befürchte dass es da noch
zu schlimmen engpässen kommt und dann
fragt sich natürlich auch wo sind
eigentlich die ganzen spendengelder
gelandet vor allem auch dass die
menschen jetzt in ihren wohnungen sitzen
und frieren müssen gibt's da nicht die
möglichkeit einer notunterkunft oder die
in appartements hotels unterzubringen
richtig die gibt es und zwar in
ahrweiler wird jetzt auch ein
containerdorf gebaut mit etwa 144
zimmern die haben etwa zwölf
quadratmeter da ist ein wc drin da ist
ein gemeinschafts eine
gemeinschaftsküche auch ein bart drin da
kann man dann alternativ hin ist aber
immer noch nicht die beste lösung und
soweit man versucht jetzt eben viele
leute sind natürlich auch privat bei
verwandten immer noch aber es wird
getanzt eine irrsinnige solidarität
untereinander die spendengelder werden
auch verteilt wir haben maik menke
gesehen er ist sachverständiger er hat
auch gibt elektroheizungen verteilt er
zum beispiel oder eben auch radiatoren
dass die leute eben sich wärmen können
also das wird schon gemacht aber es ist
trotzdem ist man ahnt dass es zu
engpässen kommen wird ist noch luft nach
oben vielen dank auch dass du vor ort
nach dem rechten geschaut hat diese
bilder mitgebracht hatten damit für sie
alle sehen können